[Music]
psychedelics are super illegal even with
all the recent media buzz MDMA known as
Molly or ecstasy and psilocybin the
active ingredient in magic mushrooms our
schedule one drugs which by definition
means they are highly addictive and have
no medical value now if you could all
kindly look under your seats what you'll
find is just a pinch right now I just
not today
today I talk about a mental health
problem that is just so big it's hard to
wrap our heads around eight million
people in the US have post-traumatic
stress disorder
15 million suffer from alcoholism 300
million people globally face depression
300 million people is all the people in
Canada times 8 8 Canada's and every
single person is sick and is hurting
can't sleep at night can't hold a job
have lost their autonomy their ability
to connect with people they're
contemplating suicide they have tried
again and again to heal and have failed
and it's not their fault what we have
available for treatment today is just
not getting the job done therapy alone
has definitely helped some but dropout
rates are high and most people maintain
their diagnosis antidepressants come
with a whole host of trade-offs here
take these pills they'll manage your
symptoms might make you feel weird in
other ways and take them from now until
forever give or take so back to
psychedelics one of the most promising
mental health treatments in the last 30
years is psychedelic assisted
psychotherapy using psychedelic
substances alongside therapy to treat
some of our most debilitating conditions
depression anxiety PTSD addiction among
others but how could that be it is fair
that some of you might be picking your
jaws up off the floor others might know
the potential of these substances from
personal experience and others here I
know our experts who you yourselves
could give your own compelling talks on
the safety and efficacy research of
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy with
that in mind here's what I'll share as
one of the 300 million who has suffered
from depression MDMA and psilocybin are
safe an important note here is that
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy is
delivered in a controlled supervised
safe setting with preparatory sessions
before reflection sessions after
enduring the drug assisted experience
picture eye shades headphones and
classical music you're tucked in under a
blanket with a therapist on your right
and a therapist on your left that sounds
pretty great without any psychedelics
and again we do see some progress with
therapy alone but when you add
psychedelics the impact goes to a whole
nother level you start seeing data for
first responders with severe PTSD who
have failed prior treatment and after
receiving and EMA assisted psychotherapy
over 50% no longer have PTSD 12 months
later that number continued to rise
without additional intervention to
two-thirds of patients no longer having
PTSD there are similarly remarkable data
for psilocybin administered in
conjunction with psychotherapy
substantially reducing depression and
anxiety in patients with with terminal
cancer again with persisting sustained
effects now the commonality across the
conditions being explored is that they
are diseases of rigidity where
destructive thoughts of others of
ourselves have over time calcified the
negative feedback loop taking us deeper
and deeper into the grooves of our own
psyche we're stuck MDMA is thought to
help PTSD in a couple ways first it's an
empath isn't it Foster's empathy and
connection this pro-social quality is
thought to enhance the rapport between
therapist and patient rapidly
accelerating the healing process second
in the brain on MDMA we see a quieting
of our fear center and an uptick in our
memory and critical thinking hubs one
theory is that this fear extinction and
memory reconsolidation allows us to face
memories of traumatic events without the
fear impulse that typically comes up and
shuts things down instead we can process
process these memories with emotions
other than fear
maybe this trauma isn't my fault the
tone of those memories start to take on
a different color one that isn't so
brutal or so haunting with depression
and anxiety and addiction we are stuck
in negative ruminations I am worthless
nothing matters alcohol controls my life
and what psilocybin and other classic
psychedelics seem to do is help us break
out of that narrative to shake things up
and to see the world in a new way the
patient anecdotes are truly astounding
themes of transformation and Awakening
themes of deep connection and unity to
everything
to nature to total strangers realizing
we are all in this together now think of
another experience described as
transformational life-changing where we
get to learn so much about ourselves
connect deeply with others and see the
world in a new way places like Stanford
change lives and change the world and
that is exactly the kind of firepower we
need behind this movement researchers
have worked tirelessly for decades for
this first opening to get these drugs
off schedule one and legally provide
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy the
first FDA approval could come as soon as
2022 that is not a lot of time to build
out a world that supports this treatment
University psychedelic research centers
and medical programs inclusive of
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy you
need to happen right now this treatment
has enormous potential but its impact
will be limited if we don't figure out a
few things first therapist training
anyone who has tried to find a therapist
lately knows it can be daunting
I thought recruiting was just for summer
internships I did not know that to find
a therapist I would also need to reach
into the depths of my rolodex ask for
referrals all in hopes of finding the
right culture fit just to be turned away
repeatedly there simply aren't enough
universities have the infrastructure to
scale this much-needed skill set the
campus the educators and most
importantly the vibrant commitments to
world-class cutting-edge treatment
second
diversity championing it is a good thing
that universities cared deeply about
creating inclusive environments because
they have huge sway in terms of shaping
our future leaders who gets educated who
gets a shot who gets the platform
universities can bring together
communities of research researchers
students patients who mirror the makeup
of all those impacted by the conditions
this treatment can heal a critical step
towards equitable treatment access and
lastly reducing stigma the Imperial
College of London and Johns Hopkins
University have already established
psychedelic research centers what if
Stanford also had a psychedelic Research
Center Harvard UCSF think about what
that would do to shape public outlook to
open people up to the possibility of
another treatment option we have made
good progress moving past the stigma of
talking about mental health problems now
it's time to start overcoming the stigma
of talking about mental health solutions
you or someone you know and love
struggles with mental health which means
you have a role to play as a donor an
innovator an advocate there is room for
everyone we are in this together so
let's get a lot of healing to a lot of
people thank you
[Applause]
[Music]